all right I feel like the first thing I
should say is how can I help you can get
me a blanket okay I'll take a nap right
here yes that's all but I mean that's a
big part of your show that's one thing
you keep saying yes throughout to
everyone is how can I help ya which is a
great message you know it's it's simple
and I think you know we're we're doing a
show about health care and Eric
manheimer who wrote the book the shows
based off of always says you know that
we should be putting the care back into
health care and that we should be
treating people like human beings not
like statistics and and or a bill you
know a chair anything like that and so
how can I help what can I do how can I
make it better you know if we all ask
that in our own lives it would be better
sorry I'm gonna go off on a tirade I'm
someone's soapbox now but it's good you
know but I mean listen this for those
who don't know tell them a little bit
about how this series came to be in it
it was a book and it was based on an
actual doctor's life
yeah yeah this guy named Eric manheimer
who's fascinating guy great guy he wrote
this book about his experience as
medical director at Bellevue for almost
20 years and and he just was kind of an
out-of-the-box thinker he was a bit
rebellious you know we kind of fought
some of the bureaucracy and things like
that and tried to get things working and
just asked how how can I help how can we
do it better what's not working he fired
the whole cardiac surgical department
because they had the highest infection
mortality rates in New York at that time
no I think in the country at that time
bold move yeah and a number of things
and you know working in a hospital that
sees patients from prisoners from Rikers
Island and and and babies - I mean just
every kind of they treat everybody from
everywhere so there's a lot of different
stories that he would encounter it was
like having him on set because any time
you sort of do something you know when
there's a real-life person whose story
this is kind of based on there's a bit
of pressure with that or did you feel
that no for sure there there is pressure
to to get it to get it right because
you're telling somebody's real-life
story as you say and and and Eric is
somebody who has committed so many years
of his life to helping
people into making a difference that you
if you make a show about it you don't
want to make it to TV II and you want to
try to make it as real as you can and
and and and do that story justice and
and those are the most exciting stories
for me are the stories that are about
real people doing real things those
those are the stories that are worth
making sure the movies about so yeah and
I think your writers were really clever
they did something that I have I can't
remember that I've ever seen in a series
where they you know they gave your
character a condition that would
normally end the story or could
potentially end the story it happened in
the first episode so cancer diagnosis
right that's a really interesting twist
where do you see that going I think it's
a it is an interesting way to go and
again it's based off Eric and his life
and his battle and an experience with
this disease that is so you know
ubiquitous is so affects so many people
and you know one thing that Eric talks
about learning from that experience was
how to be a patient and how to it
changed his the way he spoke to people
when he returned to being a doctor it
changed the way he would talk to
somebody who had cancer or any disease
for that matter or it just experiencing
something like that puts so many things
in perspective and just changed you know
the way that he thought about healthcare
even more so so humanity back in it yeah
and for max who is the fictional
character based off Eric I think you
know he spends his whole life sort of
looking at we're trying to help and I
think there's this kind of fear to be
vulnerable and to look inward and to sit
still for a min and so the character
doesn't even want to admit that he
hasn't let alone slow down and and ask
what that really means for his life and
he and yet as a wife and they have a
baby on the way so it's a lot of high
stakes with that so I hear you're
squeamish I feel like we should get
comfortable on the couch because I can
ask you okay let's do it
I hear you're squeamish if I feel like
I'm dirtying the county we've got
is this okay I feel like this is much
more comfortable yes it is do you get
squeamish with some of of the scenes I
mean listen you're a doctor yes I mean
you have to deal with blood and you have
to deal with bits and parts and stuff
it's true you get a little bit squeamish
it turns out playing a doctor on
television does not qualify you as a
real doctor okay I just learned this I
denied a cramp and I wanted to talk to
you about it but I won't look yeah
chiropractics whatever you need Oh
perfect okay but a bit squeamish not go
with my whole my whole family is is
medical my sister's my folks are doctors
yeah everywhere my uncle my clothes you
could get this is this is as proud as
they'll ever be this is the most I'll
ever be allowed to sit down at
Thanksgiving and have something
respectful to talk about amazing for you
yeah instead of like I play dress-up
today they're like get out of here don't
let no I'm a doctor anyway okay you're
back in the family but but yeah but but
yeah no to answer your question not good
with blood not and definitely a bit
squeamish and it's I'm around it all the
time at work now that's amazing and how
are you with medical jargon like do you
have to really because you're around it
with your family are you pretty good at
it or is this something you you lay in
bed at night before you go to sleep at
it I think doctors are in real life for
like I have to say what and they're
reading their books in school and
they're like what the but but yes we are
getting better with that the good news
is that my character doesn't have to say
as much of that because he's the medical
director as opposed to the surgeon or
yeah you know like Jocko who who was a
heart surgeon on the show gets stuck
with some pretty tough stuff and some
you know Moo he's got to learn that all
the instruments and everything I just
get to come in and go you're doing a
good job you know and so it's it's it's
all good this is true yeah there have
been some very famous actors who have
played doctors yes that's true I mean
there's George Clooney yeah and now
there's you yes and nobody else and
nobody else basically and people are
saying that you're the next big thing
well you you big before that I started
that rumor oh did you
New York Post I went on the internet
okay and I went to the website and I
said man that Ryan Eggold is something
he is the next George Clooney and then I
was and then it started trending so I
was the one responsible for so you know
you do feel that that's happening I feel
like if we looked at the actual comments
they'd be like what a douche wises hair
is so weird you know it's but they'd be
different they'd be different comments
probably but what is it like getting
this sort of attention now no it's it's
cool I mean it's love with the series
but they've also fallen in love with you
yeah good know it's it's it's wonderful
it's you know why I got to do blacklist
for many years and that was a great
experience and so people often
recognized me for that and then I just
did this film with with Spike Lee which
is also true story and so people come up
and be like oh you saw it and now with
this show where three or four episodes
almost out and it's really good it's so
fresh and so when someone comes up and
says I love the new show I mean it just
it means a lot because we've been
working hard and its new and it's it's I
think an exciting story to tell and it's
about people's lives you know it's about
stuff that really affects all our lives
so yeah it's cool